versus businesses daycares and churches
to close their doors we are forced to
find new ways to give back and volunteer
New York Times bestselling Arthur
Gretchen Rubin joins us with tips on how
to help your community during this time
of crisis
it's part of our partnership with
Gretchen Rubin and her award-winning
podcast happier good morning to you
Gretchen and before you get started I
have to share this with you in the
audience
Patti Rick Adela who works here with us
is at home out of an abundance of
caution self-isolation
and she just posted this it's like Vegas
at my house we're losing money by the
minute
cocktails are acceptable at any hour and
nobody knows what time it is I so love
this so you're in a position to help
what are some of the things that we can
do right now I hope that he's this thing
if she's not bad well there's a lot of
things we can do one thing we can do if
we can is to donate blood the United
States is facing a severe blood shortage
and so if you can give blood that's
great if you can give to homeless
shelters food banks meals on wheels
that's great too if you don't feel
comfortable leaving your house oh go
ahead Anthony no I was just gonna say
Gretchen if you if you if you want to
volunteer for something to help some
ways I mean other than like giving blood
are there ways to do that from home
absolutely one thing you can do is do
virtual babysitting for parents who need
a break or parents who need to get work
done you can do virtual babysitting
depending on the age of the child so you
could read a story you could play Simon
Says you could have them do Show and
Tell for you you could have them do a
performance for you to keep them busy so
that adults can do what they need to do
also points of light is a huge volunteer
organization and they have a
clearinghouse of ideas some of which you
can do from home like reaching out to
seniors who are isolated or giving
counseling by text so many people
aggression applied for unemployment in
the past two weeks so it's in the
millions those people are financially
struggling but one of the ways actually
feel better about what you're doing and
also your time is is to volunteer if you
can't give money
what can they do to kind of recharge
themselves during this very strange and
painful time in their lives well one
thing if it's possible is to do errands
for others who can't do errands whether
that's you know an older person or a
healthcare worker that can't do it
walk someone's dog pick up their
medication perhaps you are in a
neighborhood that has a neighborhood
social networking site you could set up
a helpline so that people someone who
gets injured someone who is out working
needs an errand done you could help
figure that make that match happen and
one thing that we can all do is when
we're out doing our very responsible
socially you know distance walking is we
could just smile at each other and try
to create an environment of warmth and
support at a time when we're physically
distanced but we don't have to be
socially distance that's the best advice
ever Gretchen honestly because we walk
around we're all feeling so tense a
smile never ever hurts ever it's never
it's Thank You Gretchen Gretchen thank
you very much